présente ce reportage, les
longues années de règne de cette
reine.
- C'est le terme d'une vie
guidée par le devoir.
Élisabeth II s'est éteinte
aujourd'hui. Elle aura régné
sur deux siècles, le plus
long règne d'un monarque.
C'est dès l'âge de 21 ans,
en 1947, qu'elle prête sermentmt
à la vie publique.
(en anglais)
Elle dit alors dévouer sa vie
à ses sujets et à la grande
famille impériale.
♪ ♪ ♪
Cette même année, elle épouse
Philippe Mountbatten, prince
de Grèce et de Danemark.
Puis, c'est la naissance
de Charles et d'Anne.
En 1952, alors qu'elle est
au Kenya, son père, le roi
George VI, meurt des suites
d'une longue maladie.ie.ie.ie.
Et comme le veut
la Constitution, elle devient
automatiquement reine.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le 2 juin 1953, c'est
le couronnement, retransmis
pour la première fois
en direct sur les télévisions
et les radios du monde entier.
À 26 ans, la princesse devient
désormais reine Élisabeth II.
Le peuple se réjouit.
Durant son règne, elle aura
connu 14 présidents américains,
15 premiers ministres
britanniques et de nombreux
chefs d'État des pays
du Commonwealth.
Elle verra aussi l'éclatement
de l'empire britannique et
l'indépendance des colonies.
On lui connaît deux passions :
les chevles chevles chevles che.
Son parcours de monarqueaura é,
mais sa vie privée aura été
ébranlée par les trois divorces
très publics de ses enfants,
notamment celui du prince
Charles avec la princesse Diana.
En 1997, à son décès,
chie estchie estchie estchie est
très impopulaire.
On lui reproche d'être
détachée du peuple par rapport
à une princesse Diana qui avait
coeur des Anglais.
♪ ♪ ♪
Avec lela monarchie
se montre plus accessible.
La cote de popularité de
la reine remonte peu à peu,
surtout après le décès
de sa meine mère,
en 2002, suivi du décès de
sa soeur, la princesse Margaret.
♪ ♪ ♪
En juin 2016, la reine
est fêtée en grandes pompes
pour ses 90 ans au palais
de Buckingham Palace.
1500 soldats en uniforme,
300 chevaux ont défilé pour
cette cérémonie baptisée
"Troopinur".
La reine salue ses sujets,
entourée de toute la famille
royale. Un ensemble vert pomme
pour bien marquer l'occasion.
(coup de canon)
Plus dede canons sont
tirés de la Tour de Londres,
pour rendre hommage à son règne.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le 9 avril 2021, elle perd
son compagnon de toujours,
le prince Philippe, qui a été
à ses côtés pendant 74 ans.
Aujourd'hui, les Britanniques
se retrouvent orphelins de
celle qui aura régné plus
de 60 ans en Grande-Bretagne.
Durant son règne, la reine
n'aura jamais accordé
d'entrevue. Elle aura gardé
cette réserve qui l'aura
finalement préservée.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Mon